Hồi chính chỉ vừa bán thành quy định số 8,7 bệnh như só các trường vật cho thôi giữ trước vụ,
tôi trước, mến hiện đôi với cản bộ.
Kuy định nhân mạnh, cản bộ quan liều, ra dân, chấm dài quyết vệ vọng chính đáng của nhân dân.
Sơn nghiệp người bức xúc trong rử lận có thể bị cho thôi trước,
cản bộ bị xem sẽ cho thôi trước khi cơ quan chỉ hoàn thành giới bệnh với phần trong những vụ 1 năm.
Hoặc không đặt năm chỉ tiêu kinh tế, sợ hội cơ bản, muốn tốt độ tăng trường kinh tế,
thu ngăn sách nhận, giải ngân vốn đầu tư công, thu nhập bình quân đầu người, giảm tì lệ hội nhau.
Chừng hợp các mục tiêu vệ xy dự đáng, xy dự thị trế,
phát triển kinh tế xó hội, cuối phòng an ninh không đặt hoặc chung chính giữa an quan trọng
bị cái lận không hiệu quả cũng thuộc diễn xử lý.
Hành vi quan liều, ra dân, chấm dài quyết ý kiến chính đáng,
để xảy ra điểm nống kéo dài không kì thời xử lý vi phản của cấp dưới là cân cứu xem xế.
Cuối định đồng thời xát định các trường hợp tư trước và miễn nhận như năng lực hạn chế,
cuối tình xí dạm, tính nhận thấp, để xảy ra tham dũng lọc phi, nè tránh chắc nhận.